viendra faire une petite interview
dernier couet lannes êtes prête en bouge
pas on en est une gare
on ne bouge pas pendant le signal
dernier coup dur dernier coup dur c'est
d'avoir d'avoir vu moyens des animaux
dernier coup de tête
d'avoir refusé un concert uniquement
parce que le répertoire n'était pas moi
dans les coups de coeur le dernier
concert parce que chaque fois dans un
conseil à une communication émotionnelle
qui s'établit et c'est ça qui sauve au
fait il ya des coups de poing pas encore
dans les coups de folie to you
là les coups de foudre la france entière
est suspendu a volé la france entière
est amoureuse de vous et veut savoir
non non en fait le dernier coup de
foudre c'était pour une oeuvre way we
bien les coups de gueule
avec l'année dernière et des coups de
pub dans les coups de fil mais à
quelques chiens dans les coudes rouge
mais coup de rouge
non je n'aime pas trop le genre ah bon
buvez quoi vélo c'est un week-end contre
les coins comme drogue
ma drogue c'est le cancer c'est
l'adrénaline à la présence d'un des
coups de soleil
il ya trop longtemps les six ans ah
ouais ouais je vais vous parler un peu
au soleil quand même bien pourquoi je
n'ai pas le temps au temps ça se prend
remarquez on a tous 24 heures dans la
journée donc ce type au crédit du nord
l'été vous pourriez partir un petit peu
pour vous accorder sa une fois ci non
mais c'est vrai dernier coup bar le mois
dernier à paris ouais ouais ouais
incapable de juger des concerts à ce
moment là non j'ai commencé je vais
nécessaires à sa maman vous avez les
émissions télévision mais pas des
concerts live coup de chapeau au prêtre
de notre paroisse dans les coups de
froid
la différence dans les coups de blues
moi j'ai le blues en avance oui ah bon
j'ai le blues pour tout ce qui ne s'est
pas encore produit a les yeux dans les
yeux bruns il n'y a pas si longtemps il
ya une semaine et demie